[Music]
hello everyone i'm dave parker from
turner classic movies and it's my
pleasure to be here
with the cast and filmmaker of together
together ed helms patty harrison and
writer director exec producer nicole
beckwith
sorry i'm just i am a little nervous
i've thought a lot more about being a
dad than i thought about
um making conversation with the person
carrying my baby
right well i'm nervous too to my sperm
to the donor's egg and to your uterus
cheers cheers i'd like to start class
with a cleansing breath
sometimes people just connect it's not
about being attracted to one another
so how many friends in their 20s do you
[Music]
have
at some point you will give birth to a
child and then what happens
just because you're not like together
together doesn't mean that you haven't
created a bond
paul i want to begin with you because
i'm just fascinated by how
this movie really plays with and
subverts so many of the tropes
of typical romantic movies can you tell
me about what the germ
of the idea and the tone
of the script were um yeah
uh i think when i write something i
write from curiosity because like i
wanna see
what happens or what it would be like
and i um was very
curious about a surrogate uh
relationship like it's just such an
intimate thing to end everyone as
complete strangers
and so um and i also knew that i wanted
to tell a story both
about um a man who wanted to be a father
you know i think we tell a lot of
stories about women that are like i just
want to be a mother at all costs and
i'll do it
unconventionally even and yet our
stories about
men becoming fathers tend to be either
like
accidental and they're dealing with
the sudden fatherhood or they're being
like
brought into it reluctantly um and i
think that that's wrong and i think
there are
men want to be dads and so i wanted to
tell that story
and i think we also tell a lot of
stories about surrogacy
with a melancholy you know kind of dour
tilt where we think of it as a sacrifice
or
a conflict and so i also wanted to tell
a story about a surrogate who
was aware of herself who knew her
boundaries she knew what she was capable
of and the surrogacy is additive
um because that's what it is ultimately
you're
helping to create a family and um it's a
positive thing
and uh it's still very stigmatized so
that was kind of the the germ and then
once i started writing i was like oh
look what's happening between them and
just kind of
just kind of rolled with it yeah i love
that um ed and patty
one at a time can you tell me about when
you first had a conversation with nicole
after reading
the script what were your main questions
for her
do you remember ed oh boy it was quite a
while ago
what were my questions nicole i'm sure
they were very astute
and uh they were so smart
that i can't even remember them they
were too smart for me
i think i probably asked a lot about
uh her vision for the movie i mean
there's
there is a little bit of like standard
actor director
q a when you first meet um but there i
really was curious
uh you know how
how nicole wanted to make the movie and
what what it would what she wanted it to
feel like and look like and
that a lot of those things affect my
interest in something so
uh but then also uh
well really the question you just asked
at the top
dave like what you know where did this
come from
and uh and everything that nicole's
just said i don't know somehow that it
feels like a familiar
uh part of many conversations that we've
had over the last couple years and
yeah it's awesome it's just this is a
cool story
really patty what about you what were
your biggest concerns
when you read it i think at first i was
like
why me like why at the time i felt like
i was like everything that i'm doing is
like
making jokes like i'm gonna eat a dildo
that's kind of like the space that i
felt like i was sitting in with my own
work
and so then when the script came that's
like very
like emotionally grounded and beautiful
and thoughtful
and i was like you know and then like
playing like a
cis pregnant woman i was like you know
skeptical of like if i even
it just was so out of what i believed
like my bounds were
or like what opportunities that would
you know ever fall into
my lap so it was like very um
i just like didn't know where to start
so it was
pretty like i think uh nicole was
nicole was doing a lot of soothing like
me because i was like okay like
just tell me exactly how you want her
voice to sound and
like i will do that like what do you see
her talking like oh my god like just
tell me just force me to do it
don't be afraid to hurt my feelings
because i want to do exactly what you
want to do
and nicole's like well i also want this
to be like a rewarding experience for
you and i was like no
no no um it was like i was pretty
i was really nervous after so it was
just like yeah like ed said there's like
these clarifying questions about like
tonally like
where do you see this because
um i think there are a lot of you know
like
preconceived or like expectations like
with
ed or like uh like
what asking me to do it how i felt about
my own work or like how people perceived
my work it's like
even talking about it like to other
people earlier on i was like yeah i'm
like working on this movie soon with
like
ed helms and we're gonna be doing this
thing and they're like oh is it like
slapstick is it going to be like real
it's like
you both together like are very you know
uh very deep in into comedy
i guess for lack of i just look for lack
of a better way to say that but um
uh so i definitely had like a million
questions
and i don't remember exactly what they
were but i know that
i asked them with sheer terror
a natural childlike curiosity
nicole did you uh i almost like hesitate
to ask this question did you
ever have anybody who you were talking
to about this movie or who read the
script who maybe was gonna put money in
or something
say to you oh but can't they get
together
oh yeah
oh yeah uh yeah it's a i mean it's a
real
journey um to make i hate using the word
journey
sorry um but it is like a it's
a long windy road to try to get a movie
made it's so hard
um and uh there were many times where i
felt like i was almost there and then
there would be like a but maybe they get
together or like but maybe we can like
film them
you know they're maybe they can go on
maybe they live together or maybe they
do this and it was always just like i
can't
there's no way i can't like the movie
should not be made
uh if that is what would
happen to it so i was very stubborn um
and very broke and very
uh hopeful that it would come together
the way that it
had to be and part of that is also um
anthony brandisia my producing partner
um you know i think like a lesser
partner would have been like
well maybe i mean like if it means we
can get the movie but he really wasn't
he was like right
dialed into um what the movie
is and what it was always meant to be
and where it should go and how it should
happen and so he
he was up and out of those meetings with
me just like
just like i was his boots were just as
much on fire yeah
did any of you three in the entire
process ever have conversations on set
where you thought
okay here's a moment where even though
they're thankfully not going to get
together
matt and anna here's a moment where we
can kind of play with the audience a
little bit
and play up the the usual tropes and
kind of psych the audience out
that to make them think that maybe they
will only to
stick to our guns and have them not get
together later or did you never even
want to go down
even that road can i jump in here
yeah so it's interesting there i think
we did
there was a lot of discussion about this
sort of what kind of vibe
was being portrayed by different scenes
and and
i cannot really only speak for myself
that
i was really not i
did not want to convey
any kind of romantic uh inkling
because i knew that the audience would
be just projecting like hell
the whole time so as
as much as i could pull back from that
and just be like authentic and earnest
and let the story be what it is
i knew that we would be sort of fighting
upstream against audience
projection already and i didn't want to
feed into that
so i think that that the movie kind of
beautifully winds up subverting some of
that projection from audience
audiences uh but for my part i did not
want to lean into that
ever accepted it's the right that's the
right vibe you know
i think like also there's a scene where
anna comes in and it's like lamps moving
and
it's like the hand of the belt and it's
in bed and it is very intimate and i was
like head to toe
has to be had to tell like i don't want
to see them lying in bed side by side
um and then you know you don't think
about it at the time because there is so
much intimacy between them
but when they hold hands on the bench um
eating candy then you're like oh right
they like really haven't
touched aside from like the birthing
class and stuff but they they
we haven't seen them hug you know and
that was all very
um i feel like that was just very
natural because we were all three of us
very much on the same page i don't think
we ever were like
do we want to put a hand on a hip or a
shoulder here like we just
knew you know the shared understanding
of what the like physical language was
and and that's partly why you know the
birthing class is so
you know hard and partly why the the
handhold at the end is so impactful
um um yeah because of the
because of the restraint and just the
space that their
relationship lives in patty as a gay guy
i was so jazzed to learn
after watching this movie because i have
to admit i was not familiar with you
that you are a trans performer playing
this
cisgender lead role in this film
i can't recall that happening before and
i think it's so special and you did such
a great job
is that meaningful to you as a concept
um it is it was like a
huge you know thing at first
uh to contemplate you know my
involvement
in in the movie and what it would mean
and all of the optics of it and all the
all everything that people would project
on to it and
it you know i was anxious thinking about
it
and like wondering like oh my gosh what
does what does all this mean and like
how could people like take this
um the wrong way or something like that
or project something negative onto this
but
at that when i like kind of cleared all
of that and was just like okay well what
do i want to do and it's like well i
want to like
act in this movie like that's kind of
like
where i sat in the in my individual
journey about it but like i hope that
there are more uh like a million more
opportunities not just for trans people
to play
roles that aren't explicitly written
trans but like
any marginalized person i think that um
we're in a very interesting um
space in in our industry now where
there's like more
public conversations about
representation and involvement
like inclusion writers and stuff and
that's great but i think that
like you know all representation isn't
great representation
it's like a box right people box you in
people have their expectations of you
and if you're marginalized in our
society in any way people have
perceptions of you that are like very
rigid
and those uh perceptions of you
affect like what opportunities you get
if the person who's like in charge of
hiring someone
or writing something for someone um is
like
has their own box for you and i know
that's like a big part of the industry
it's like you know what's your type
like what what do you play and there's
people that feel like really typecast
and stuff like that
um this is such a long-winded answer but
uh i think like
a lot there are a lot of things that
feel even though they're
well-meaning it feels like you're not
necessarily removing the box
they're just elevating the box and
putting the box in the spotlight and
being like
we cast like a trans person in this but
it's like the trans person is still in a
box
it's just there's a flashlight on it and
this
movie to me felt like i the box
was was gone and like this opportunity
felt like i was
entering like a space that i just really
never imagined i would get
and this just felt like such an exciting
thing and it's like
i don't i'm sometimes i wonder i'm like
i don't know if i'll get like an
opportunity like that again
it can feel like that sometimes i'm
optimistic but
yeah it does mean a lot to me nicole one
other thing i really appreciate about
this movie it is in in some scenes this
kind of fascinating hyperverbal
uh film but then you also have these
moments kind of peppered through that
are silent and very poignant
where whether they're kind of picking
the the pink color and taking the
swatches off the wall
or if when uh matt is feeling the the
tummy
the baby kicking in the tummy or my
favorite when anna walks out of the
shower did you specifically want those
silent moments to counterbalance the
more dialogue heavy stuff and if so did
you have them
spaced out in the movie in a kind of
almost mathematical way or am i reading
way too much into this
i feel like when i'm writing i'm i'm
like
the first audience to the movie where
i'm just kind of like the stenographer
taking things down being like oh my
goodness that's what's happening
um and so i think that that balance
uh came naturally i think if you've
just absorbed a lot of um vocal
uh connectivity and exchanging of
information
um then just naturally my inclination is
let's let that steep and while that
steeping
will take in this visual um this visual
level of communication
um but yeah i don't i don't outline
anything
and i don't uh i don't i'm not very
structured
so i just you know i just let it i just
let it roll
and i i think some would say i'm
indulgent
in my restraint which is a riddle
in and of itself but i do love to i love
quiet i love slowness i love
space i love to just see what happens um
and so that's where that just comes from
ed there's so many great supporting
characters in this movie that's another
thing i love is that these supporting
characters who would normally kind of be
these stock portrayals have so much
personality to them
my favorite maybe if i'm saying her name
right is sufi bradshaw
who played the technician the medical
technician i thought she was
hilarious i loved everything she did
when you think back to
whether it's tignotaro or nora dunn or
all these great people fred melamed
who was like the biggest wild card
on the set where from take to take it
could just be something
totally crazy different in keeping you
on your toes
i think fred melamed to me was like
it just it he to me is such an attach
he's such an anchor of hollywood like
he's
been around for so long he's been in so
many important
and meaningful movies maybe just in my
life i don't know but
he's just the ultimate ultimate
journeyman
and i was so thrilled to to be able to
act with him
and he's such a warm funny guy
and he he's someone who just had like
between takes
he just would really engage with those
huge warm eyes that just suck you in and
then
and like tell you a story about some
other actor
some crazy experience and and with that
that voice that's just that just rolls
out like gravy i mean
he's just he he's amazing i don't know
i i loved every minute on set with him
patty was there someone you were
particularly excited to work with
obviously you and julio torres have a
a history together but who were you most
excited to work with
there were so many of my close friends
are
in this movie that it is i think it's
astronomically kind of like crazy
to think of like that like you know i
didn't have any control over the casting
process
but like i mean like greta titleman
and joe firestone and julio torres
like those are all people who are like
extremely close friends of mine
it was so like amazing to have them
each like on set at different times
because
it was like a very you know
nerve-wracking experience
at times just to like step outside my
comfort zone
and like it was there was so much
comfort
like in having them there like i don't
think there was like one specific person
i mean tig just
it is like was so formative in
in me kind of like turning toward doing
comedy so it was like
very it was very intimidating um
but yeah the cast is insane rosalind
chow
like joy luck club and like
um what dreams may come like those
movies
were so were like
a big part of my childhood and like
it was i don't know there were just so
many moments when i was like
oh wow well you all
mesh beautifully together and together
see what i did there uh and i
congratulate you on
a really original and terrific film so
nicole beckwith ed helms patty harrison
thank you so much
for taking the time and thanks to all of
you for sticking around
tonight bye everybody thank you
thank you
[Music]